pinpoint pass and his match up tonight
lebron james james drives and gets to
the room easily for the first two points
i mean the cliches in our league
are at an all-time high are you saying
i'm using cliches as finney smith comes
up short if you tell me we're
collaborating right now then yes
well james throws it up davis throws it
down the lakers are clearly giving it
110
the best player you have a
responsibility to do that
also off the turnover james to davis
davis gets inside count it
and one got hit knocked that down and a
free throw coming up for anthony davis
schroeder sweet pass inside little slip
pass and anthony davis able to finish
as a sixth man as anthony davis lines up
the three
gasol keeps it alive in a new 14 james
way outside
knocks down the three earlier did have
seven points but also had four assists
vogel has had to have his coaches
meetings here in the arena bowl
because they can't have them in the
office mike all right rachel
for all the teams to talk as doncic gets
inside puts that in
lucca and lebron as this presentation of
nba christmas day continues after this
message
and a word from our abc stations
telling schroeder to go through davis
backs in a little jump hook
love the patience man's triple double in
a loss on a loss
[Laughter]
doncico's drives puts it up banks at
home with five tenths of a second
remaining ability to roll
catch and finish with someone like
lebron james
he'll be a tremendous asset james tries
another three
nails that one his second three-pointer
because their first four games this
season at home
meanwhile a three-game road trip to
start for the mavericks
high arcing three for anthony davis who
now has 12 points
doing a better job of moving out to
basketball and looking to make plays
making the extra pass caruso again
finding davis
[Applause]
[Music]
doncic banks at home all right here's a
question for you
up top to james davis reposts
powell trying to stay with him forces
him a fall away shot but still doesn't
bother him
reverses gets inside layup won't go
davis the rebound quickly throws it
ahead caldwell pope
feeds james and throws it down that's a
beautiful fast break
when this team is absolutely a terror to
defend
no matter who rebounds the basketball
off to the races look at lebron james
this late in the game this late in his
career full head of steam
finishing in transition like he's a
rookie spectacular job
[Applause]
5 on the 24 falling away
got it 14 for lebron james the lead is
10.
you can't play any better defense than
luca does on this possession
keeps him in front leaves leaves this
the ground once lebron does contest the
shot
off balance fading away that's just
beautiful offense
a spectacular game for kyrie irving
today
kyle kuzma too strong davis took it away
from powell and
throws it back up off the glass you look
at what was the previous
shortest gap between winning a title and
starting the next season as you
mentioned as james
scores easily quick timeout from
carlisle got by finney smith to drive it
and finish
richardson harassing schroeder davis
gets it floats it up and he is just
scored and what have i done
no he plays the bet he felt good about
it
he doesn't feel good sitting home today
james backs up knocks down another
three-pointer
defensive plays by luca but how about
lebron toying with the basketball
jab step just looking to be friends like
that i needed somebody to tell me
look don't do it right doncic quickly
scores the
players have got to get in the fight and
do the dirty work
doncic steps back and hits the three
point only the second three-pointer he's
attempted to this one remember anthony
davis when he was in new orleans middle
of the season look what that did
to the pelicans that that year
nice floater gets up gets a nice bounce
goes in it's cut to 11.
doncic now picked up by kuzma step back
three pointers up rattles in luke
cadence now with 23. they needed that
which trying to deny lebron james using
that big
huge hand james goes back door gets
inside and reverse
nice pass nice finish
what would you do if you hit a game
winner at the buzzer how would you react
i would run off too not believing it
doncic was a beautiful floater the
subtle shots that
it's not a shot with a compliment i was
asking
if he did okay funny man i've had one
since grandma school that's for sure
davis knocks down the three-pointer
now what does that translate to
[Applause]
i don't know but they're i mean it's a
supremely talented team
it's so vital for the mavericks
because he's such a good defender is to
make sure he remains
assertive offensively as davis knocks in